Recently, Jeff Bezos announced that he
would be going to space with his brother
on July 20 using New Shepard. This would not only
make him the first billionaire to go to space
but more importantly the first owner to use his
own rocket. It should also be mentioned that
this will be New Shepard’s first crewed flight to
space. Considering this, Jeff’s spaceflight is not
a joyride by any means. No, it’s a statement piece
specifically designed to destroy the skeptics.
For years, people have talked down on Blue Origin
discounting their achievements as mere copies
and laughing at their slow pace. But, as
Jeff Bezos steps down from Amazon to fully
focus on Blue Origin, the trajectory of
Blue Origin is about to radically change.
So, here’s the story of Blue Origin and
how Jeff Bezos will ravage the haters.
Before we jump into the video, let’s address the
elephant in the room which is of course SpaceX.
There’s no question that SpaceX is way ahead
of Blue Origin and that’s unlikely to change.
But that’s ok. Blue Origin does not need to be the
best space company out there to be a leader in the
industry. This video is about how Blue Origin will
disprove the notion that the company is a joke
and how Blue Origin will grow to be the number #2
space company in the world. With that being said,
let’s take a look back at the roots of Blue
Origin. Blue Origin was originally founded
on September 8, 2000 which is ironically almost 2
years before SpaceX. At the time, Jeff Bezos was
actually in a pretty rough position financially
as that was during the midst of the dotcom crash.
Amazon stock had already crumbled from $113
to just $45, but the fall was far from over.
By September of 2001, Amazon stock would fall to
under $6 per share which wiped out 95% of Jeff’s
wealth. Fortunately, Amazon stock has since
recovered to well over $3000 per share today,
but that rise was by no means guaranteed at the
time. Clearly, Jeff ended up starting Blue Origin
during uncertain times, but something that was
absolutely certain though was his love for space.
You see, Jeff had been dreaming of pushing forward
the space industry since his high school years.
In fact, Jeff wrapped up his 1982 high
school valedictorian speech with quote,
“Space, the final frontier. Meet me there.” So,
Jeff would invest the money he did have into
rocket engine development. No one really knows the
specifics as to what they were working on as Blue
Origin was extremely secretive with their plans,
but we did get a couple of hints here and there.
In 2003 for instance, Blue Origin would start to
buy large portions of land in Texas presumably for
testing purposes. And in 2004, Jeff Bezos would
actually have a lunch meeting with Elon Musk
to discuss their space companies and the future
of the industry. According to Elon Musk, Jeff was
constantly proposing ideas that SpaceX had already
tried and discarded. Apparently, he advised Jeff
to trash these ideas, but Jeff would go ahead
and try them anyway to find out for himself.
Jeff wasn’t in any rush to build up the company
as fast as possible. By this point, amazon stock
recovered quite a bit. So, he was in no rush
to win commercial contracts or launch a rocket.
He strongly believed that slow and steady was the
key to victory. That’s how he built up Amazon, and
that’s how he was going to build up Blue Origin.
In fact, their mission statement proclaims, “We
are not in a race...We will go about this step by
step because it is an illusion that skipping steps
gets us there faster. Slow is smooth, and smooth
is fast.” Evidently, Jeff didn’t care about speed,
but what he did care about was experimentation
and innovation. One of his earliest ideas was to
vertically land New Shepard which dates back to
2005. A common misconception is that vertically
landing rockets/boosters was Elon’s idea and that
Jeff copied it. But in reality, this idea is not
original to either of these guys. The idea to
vertically land rockets is a classic within the
space industry and dates back to the 1930s. For
instance, in the 1959 movie, the Sky Calls, we can
see a rocket landing that’s basically identical to
that of Falcon 9 and New Shepard. So, this is not
a new idea by any means. SpaceX and Blue Origin
simply made this fan fiction a reality. Anyway,
moving forward, Jeff would do an interview in 2008
where he revealed his plans for New Shepard. His
goal was to conduct an uncrewed launch in
2011 and a crewed launch in 2012. Clearly,
these dates wouldn’t quite pan out, but that’s
basically the case with every space plan. In April
of 2015, Blue Origin would finally conduct their
first uncrewed test flight of the New Shepard.
Unfortunately, the booster would crash during the
landing, however, the capsule would land safely.
Though it took forever for Blue Origin to conduct
their first launch, there is definitely some truth
to Jeff’s philosophy of slow and steady wins the
race. Since that first launch, Blue Origin has
conducted 14 launches of the New Shepard, all of
which were 100% successful. And this is why I am
so confident that Jeff will indeed fly to space
this summer. The July 20th date may not hold up
because of logistical, technical, and/or weather
related delays. But these factors shouldn’t push
back the flight more than a couple of days
or weeks in the worst case. Completing this
flight will bring Blue Origin more interest than
ever before. As we discussed at the beginning,
Jeff would be the first owner to ride in his
own rocket. And the fact that he’s willing to
be part of the first crew speaks volumes about how
much he trusts his product. With Virgin Galactic,
for instance, Richard Branson has been teasing a
ride on SpaceShipTwo for years. Richard, however,
was never willing to be the first to test his
planes. And throughout their history, a pilot
was even killed during a test flight. So, let’s
not forget that rockets and space are extremely
dangerous and things have gone wrong. As a result,
Jeff completing a flight on new shepard would
give potential customers a level of confidence
that is unparalleled within the industry. Now,
I know a lot of you guys will point to Falcon 9’s
reliability, and that is absolutely true. But,
New Shepard and Falcon 9 aren’t really comparable.
Falcon 9 is an orbital rocket that cost $10s of
millions per seat. New Shepard is a suborbital
rocket with a ticket cost of about $250,000
per seat. Also, I know that the first New
Shepard ticket was sold for $28 million,
but that was more of a fundraising effort and
the buyer paid a massive premium to be the first
civilian to ride New Shepard. With that being
said, Blue origin will dominate the sub $1 million
space tourism industry over the next decade which
will be the vast majority of the space tourism
market itself. Blue Origin’s only competitor
within this market is Virgin Galactic who
doesn’t have nearly as strong of a track record.
So, Jeff’s spaceflight will solidify the company’s
future in space tourism and be the first step
in disproving the haters. New Shepard is just
a suborbital rocket though. To solidify their
position as a space leader, they also need to
have a strong orbital rocket, and that’s where
New Glenn comes into play. Blue Origin has been
developing new glenn since 2012 and they currently
plan to launch the behemoth in the fourth quarter
of 2022. Now, that date may not come true, but
New Glenn development truly is in the homestretch.
By far the hardest part of developing a rocket
is the rocket engines. New Glenn is supposed to
use the BE-4 engine, but New Glenn is not the only
rocket using this engine. United Launch Alliance
actually contracted Blue Origin to build BE-4
engines for their upcoming Vulcan Centaur rocket
which is still expected to launch at the end of
this year. This means that the engines are almost
ready to go. Assuming that the Vulcan Centaur
launches at the end of this year or early 2022,
New Glenn can’t be far behind. Even if they don’t
hit the q4 2022 date, 2023 and 2024 would be
highly likely launch dates. Let’s just say that we
see New Glenn take flight by 2025. With a payload
capacity of 45 metric tons, New Glenn will be the
second largest fully reusable rocket ever built,
only beaten out by Starship. If New Glenn beats
Starship to a successful orbital flight, New Glenn
would temporarily be the largest fully reusable
rocket. This of course comes along with a plethora
of commercial contracts and interest. Blue Origin
has already attracted several commercial partners,
and I’m sure they’ll make quite a bit of money as
a launch provider. But, what’s really interesting
with new glenn though is lunar missions. Since
the very beginning, returning to the moon has
been one of Jeff Bezos primary intentions. They’ve
got the Blue moon and the human landing system,
and though Blue Origin didn’t win the Artemis
contract, they aren’t giving up on the moon by
any means. If we say that Blue Origin completes
a crewed spaceflight using New Glenn by 2030,
it’s quite likely that Blue Origin will get
humans to the moon in the early to mid 2030s.
Again this will be nearly a decade after
SpaceX, but that doesn’t take away from the
fact that Blue Origin could very well reach the
moon before any other country. This means that
Blue Origin will be one of three organizations
that have the ability to put humans on the moon.
And I’m confident that Blue Origin will be the
one to leverage this ability. Here’s the thing,
SpaceX’s main goal is to make humans a
multiplanetary species by settling Mars. So, the
moon will not be their primary focus. Meanwhile,
Nasa’s main focus is research and development,
so they don’t really care about the moon beyond
building a research base and conducting in depth
research. This gives Blue Origin the perfect
opportunity to be the ones that commercialize
the moon and near earth space throughout the
2030s. This includes space manufacturing,
space energy production, space tourism,
space hotels, and so on and so forth.
Jeff’s primary thesis has always been
“We have to go to space to save earth.”
Though Jeff thinks it’s important
to research other planets like Mars,
he thinks the primary purpose of space is to serve
people on Earth whether that be reducing pollution
on earth by manufacturing in space or providing
people on earth with an exotic travel destination.
Considering this, over the long term, I
believe that SpaceX will be the colonists,
government space agencies will be the scientists,
and Blue Origin will be the commercialists. And
this role starts as soon as Jeff Bezos
successfully completes his spaceflight,
destroying the haters and opening up the gates
for commercialization. Do you guys think that Blue
Origin is overly scoffed at? Comment that down
below. Also, drop a like if you would like to see
Blue Origin disprove the skeptics. And of course,
consider joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.